put that cookie down down down put it
down the whole V logs just gonna be out
doing DS um
damn your wife's cookies are delicious
that is still one of the most amazing
things is that Phil Harmons performance
so I'll bet you of course
um but uh what a waste of a perfectly
good Phil Hartman in that movie I bet it
small soul jerseys like oh no come on
you sounds your only thing I actually
like in their movie no I here's the
funny thing and this is what I really
wanted a I do kind of like Schwartz that
actually it's it's not a bad idea for a
film and even on paper it almost work uh
everyone always places is like you know
one of the worst Christmas Phil's and
the dumbest excuses for like trying to
cash in and stuff but it's actually odd
not having ever said oh there's always
Christmas story - yes there's much much
worse uh for me when I saw this movie um
I saw it actually what kind of the idea
that this this could work a Sinbad was
not banished from Hollywood Atlanta but
funny yeah glad when nothing's funny
anymore like he had a sitcom that I
can't remember I was young so I can
marry was any good or not a lot of
people say it wasn't but I remember like
yeah like it was just here's nothing
else it whatever and I Sinbad to me was
always very inoffensive but not very
funny to me I've never hated Sinbad oh
yeah I only made me laugh because I
don't I know there are other comedians
that I think are not funny but more
obnoxious uh so I never hated submit but
it was Sinbad was never comedian I
sought out like never acquired a disease
that seems like a nice guy I just you
know and then he runs around and he does
stand-up and some people watch him and
some people enjoy him and good luck
no no problems here I didn't I actually
cuz he I mean really at judging all the
way he just disappeared oh it is a
career kill you know and then he came
back for one lesser Jake Lloyd for
something that was like a starting point
and another Star Wars answers so say you
get this movie with which Schwarzenegger
who is done comedy before and to be fair
not that bad it not wins Kindergarten
Cop ya cannot go and copy I'm he's
something Puma yeah I be tough it's like
always in a little awkward how funny is
like cuz I'm a secret to walk into
comedy or something but it's like he's
legitimately funny and a lot of stuff
too so you can't watching us like oh
he's the typical dad trying to get a toy
weird choice but he can do it and the
one clip they showed over and over on
the train one funny what makes it work
is that he's not he's obviously not the
David Schwarzenegger playing the typical
daddies yeah he's a workaholic and every
typical dad is Arnold Schwarzenegger
when uh but there's a scene that scene
they played over and over the trailer
which is what a few playing scenes in
the movie is when he trips Sinbad I
think with like a remote-control car he
just gives it's something only
Schwarzenegger can do it just which I
goes oh poor baby
Boop runs often II give this weird ass
file and it's amazing and we oh and we
watch this movie like or the trailer yet
although it's gonna be funny or not but
that's seen this funny yeah it's like
Batman and Robin it's like
Schwarzenegger is so Crazy's like the
two ton gorilla in the room you just
don't know what he's gonna do but it's
probably gonna be funny so they're
intentionally or not so I was kind of
looking forward to this movie knowing it
could suck uh but I didn't know it could
suck this bad um for such a funny setup
for a movie and even sorry this subplot
with this like division of Santa Clauses
like selling you you know like second
grade toys is that like these are funny
set up these are good ideas uh but then
it goes from mostly just not very funny
and awkwardly done and just whatever it
just kind of dumb - amazingly batshit
what the fuck this is the most idiotic
thing I've ever seen in the fucking
climax the climax is like beyond
insulting you can tell like any even the
look kids watch are like no no this what
is a generic family film too obnoxious
yeah exactly and I mean it goes from
just in trying to you know the extremes
of trying to get this turbo man doll
witches
again a great setup because we've seen
people go insane to get these this is
mostly satirizing the Cabbage Patch Kid
phenom and I think and when there's
video of people going in trampling over
people now we just call Black Friday
honestly but before they're just doing
this for a toy I would say Cabbage Patch
Kids this is this is just this systemic
of that whole nineties thing where we
add let's see let's let's go back I
think we're doing cabbage I think more
Tickle Me Elmo the Furby
no man but you don't have say though
it's start with Democrats kids and that
started this whole thing of like a Black
Friday yes it started but I think the
real spoof was what was going on in the
night yes cuz know every or there was
some other piece of shit toy that for
some reason everybody heard of yeah um
so so it was spoofing that and it's it's
a good idea it's actually not a bad idea
for you know commentary and stuff and he
wanted came out at the right time
because I think all of us were just kind
of sick of that whole craze of like a
trip yeah you fucking grown adults you
know get your asses off the Walmart
floor and act like human beings I'm
running around like yeah so is I just
hate that no I hate it too I really
fucking a bad shit a lot I mean we're
going to be a consumers culture no
matter what but for God's sakes
show a little did yet at least pretend
you have some humanity Headley's you
know dude don't let the media win don't
let their cameras feel easy look at
these monkeys and the fucking idiot
stuff they're doing it's like don't
don't let them win don't be animals and
I was through a commercial where you're
gonna see the products that you're gonna
want anyway yeah that's all about the
media it's like look at the monkeys
acting crazy then they run
advertisements in between the videos of
the monkeys acting great ya know it's um
circle man we're all prisoners man
so they're coping this great movie this
great comedy really kind of about that
evil which Ward's a nigger in the role
if you did it right I think you could
made it work uh and they just go for
every super safe family-friendly
you know junk food that you know doesn't
really have a mind or anything
like that and then it goes to just you
know real insulting insane stuff in the
end and I this movie you know this movie
needed to be it needed to be liar liar
yeah like it the closest thing I can
think of to this film would be liar liar
and there's a case where it is corny it
is corny it is sappy it goes a little
crazy at the end but it never completely
goes over the top batshit crazy nuts it
no point is Jim Carrey flying on a
rocket pack and like it knew exactly how
to have a strange tone but work within
it and then I'm step too far outside and
in this movie though like just
completely blows it and nobody looks so
when jim Kerr takes off the mask they're
like Jim Carrey that was like he he
talks to this kid he picked him out of
the crowd he obviously has the build up
of it even the toy upper lip ah this is
talking about it hurt when he gets down
we finally gets out what about rocket
pack that actually works and he comes
down it takes the helmet off his own
wife is like Arnold Schwarzenegger is
that you and yeah so that that's just
its own realm
um awful um I love your climax is
ridiculous
who said you could talk to my good IMAX
um yeah that was just our house almost a
sock where it's the edge we'll see in
the movie um but even that's see you at
the puppet cookie down it's like I'm
listening to us I'm like this I should
be laughing at this like this is
supposed to be land somewhere in there
laugh at it before the wrong reasons you
laugh at it cuz the scene is just so
mishandled yeah like open it is so
bizarre then it ends up being funny
despite the fact that they did
everything humanly possible to not make
it funny yeah it's one of those things
where it's like I know there's a fine
scene of your but you're not giving it
to me and more is it even Hansel what
makes it strangely funny cuz it's just
like it's just I'm looks for things they
put the cookie down and it's so over the
top and you're like this is funny but
not for the right reasons if you're not
being legitimately funny it's just crazy
yeah that's what's making it funny you
know and uh Jake Lloyd
poor kid who had simultaneously both the
best and worst agent in the world cuz he
got a Schwarzenegger movie and then Star
Wars after it's this you know what that
they're done my terrible director that
agent I yeah I don't know whether to
like give his agent an award or have
them or anything yeah have them arrested
because on the one hand it's like that
is an incredible job to take a child
actor who has no talent I mean not that
bad I always see them in those two movie
abs you know is very no no let's just be
honest no talent and that's okay he's a
kid yeah then how many actual kids are
good actors I can tell you it's probably
like five percent of all children yeah
any time you watch home movies that kids
have made themselves and like even our
own they're terrible
like inside it's it's understandable
goes beyond is we got show about saying
Jake Lloyd is a bad actor he joins a
long list of almost every kid on the
planet who is but that agent that
incredibly yet somehow was able to
convince directors this kid had talent
and I I don't I know how that ain't you
did it I just I don't know it's amazing
I mean if you could bottle that like you
can sit you could sell snow to an Eskimo
so yeah and he's in this end to be fair
like he is bad but he's not a phantom
that's bad everyone's a kid yeah if you
want to thank the early person you can
blame are the agent who obviously did a
good job selling Jake Lloyd pawning him
off into some like child actor slavery
ring um and the the casting aid the
casting people in the directors like you
could have taken one look and said this
isn't gonna work
it's one instead they stuck with it and
just like Phantom Menace is like all you
needed to do was like Amman read five
lines be like now now this kid does not
have what it takes this is not Haley
Joel Osment it's not gonna work instead
Lucas decided for whatever reason no
this is exactly what I want I'm gonna go
with it special effects are a tool much
like I am a tool and women and blame
everybody around it I never blame the
kid he's a oh yeah there's nothing you
know honestly
all in unusual what they did to him by
letting him starring hahahahaha I mean
really that then well we've all talked
about the interview he had likely I ever
he's practically like this he's like
like he just so the poor guy looks so
traumatized like I got my life only
understand about not be all tough enough
guys like no completely understandable I
mean if you're a little bit which would
look good I don't wish it will no not at
all to say that anything I completely
understand he ruined the Phantom Menace
is to complete now remove Lucas from
this yeah John and with both you know
bees wasps key to is that with both
movies you know he's not good in it I am
so distracted by the amount of terrible
in the rest of it that he's really kind
of a side note for me oh yeah no way
more worse things in it than just Jay
glowing yeah and uh I like I said it's
one of those words I feel bad that so
many people pick on it but didn't see
what could have been there with jiggle
all the way I know it sounds crazy but I
really do think a legitimately funny
comment comedy even with Schwarzenegger
and Sinbad in the leads I think if it
was I I don't hate Sinbad I'm I can't
think of anything I've seen where I
thought he was particularly funny but
he's never Oh sad bad must be crap it's
like I you love me this way I've never
found a particularly funny but he's
never annoyed me you know his presence
in a comedy like was never the cause of
the badness and as I said Schwarzenegger
and something like Kindergarten Cop like
was so amazing when like is very yeah it
was very funny in twins it it totally
could have worked in the hands of
competent people yeah I would want to
see like an eye even right then uh
direct this as you know it is a day
there you know I would like to see that
work uh like it was too busy remaking
Ghostbusters a fourth time yeah well I
was gonna say kiss was that movie did
evolution there is satellite baby yeah
yeah like that's right cuz he did twins
and Kindergarten Cop Danny did he Nukem
Ivanka I thought I could be wrong again
sanitation but you know it could be
wrong um but yeah it's one of those
things where there I think there is a
right way to direct Schwarzenegger in
both in action and comedy there's a
right way to direct him and yeah it just
we've seen it done badly in action films
and dramas and we've seen it done badly
in comedies uh but we see it done well
in both also yeah I'm trying to think of
anything I like to this movie and I just
side as I was like what I know yeah I
think I was just hitting that point
where like I say what liar liar we know
these clothes shit in cliches the
overworked or the workaholic father not
paying attention the kid gets his
comeuppance then at the end realizes his
lesson but looks like it's not gonna be
with the kids I have to go through some
sort of big climax again to it's just at
the point where that was starting to get
really really old and done and we go
kiss you and the wind simple music they
even fucking play Nutcracker and this
that's where it's like know you've given
up as soon as you play Nutcracker in
your Christmas movie and the entire John
Williams to rewrite the Nutcracker like
you did it yeah you know boy you're just
playing Nutcracker it's just it's so
obvious what you're doing this issue for
me is and this is especially true in
comedies I don't care if something's
been done before I don't I don't have
the hang up of like oh it always needs
to be new and there can't be any cliches
anywhere I don't care if there's cliches
in it it's what you do with those
cliches if you can make it fun and
entertaining then I'm going to overlook
I'm pretty forgiving I'm really willing
to overlook a lot of it but if it's not
funny if it's not entertaining and it's
just a series of cliches I'm like no no
and that's what I say no no no because a
lot a lot of people hard for me it's
like you know a lot of things have
already been done and yes and I believe
that you know I believe that theory was
that there's only like five stories in
the world and where you can tell no I
totally believe that there's a reason we
have archetypes like this this stuff
goes back to Adam and Eve like the early
primitives telling stories around the
campfire in the caves yeah no I mean
this is and these stories are always
gonna exist we're getting those guys
type stories my guess is even back
they had some people who knew how to
tell a story and other people who didn't
and the ones who did we're telling the
same story again but it wasn't
interesting and you know what they did
they probably clobbered him over the
head native so know if you're just
really like the boy who cried wolf and
every night you read the boy who cried
wolf you would get a little sick of the
boy who cried wolf and after a while you
get look this is a good story of but key
something have you sweet Oh story oh and
then maybe they make a more entertaining
version yeah they make the boy an alien
and the wolf fishy but it's like whoa
what the fuck's going on here it's like
just do something a little different or
interesting and make it work into the
story as well uh you know just have fun
do for all to be fair I don't think I've
seen Arnold Schwarzenegger on a rocket
pack fly surprisingly amazing that was
the one thing I hadn't seen yet yeah i
guess that's new but that wasn't good
yeah
at least not good for the right reasons
if um so yeah it's uh I don't why I want
to do this one so early I guess all the
ones I want to talk about are you should
christmas-related one I was like you
know we got enough Christmas one for
when December Rose rolls around so let's
just do I just you said it I was trying
to think I'm like I don't even know what
to say it's just like that's just a bad
camera I want to talk about because like
I said there's so many people are just
like oh it's a bad idea it's a bad
concept no it's a good idea and I really
feel bad one of the ideas that bad yeah
I feel bad when an idea is just like you
know oh this was dead on arrival nothing
could say that no thinks a lot that
could work with it I could actually see
the film being pulled off it just wasn't
um fortunate you're in the movie like
that is not a dead on arrival idea once
you start though throwing Schwarzenegger
Plus Jake Lord and Sinbad I may see
where the arguments coming from that
this may not have made the denim
rightful ya know I things none of none
of those not one of those goes together
this is no money no and don't get rough
you're not gonna get around breaking
Alma Terry with this so you're not going
to get your next thank you for smoking
with or what today I know that but you
could still die maybe anyone
those in your movie alone you might be
able to survive but all three like none
of them go together a completely clash
um so yeah I think that's about it um
still not a good comedy vine but I just
want to give some great that there was
at least the possibility was there even
which were to maker in it um so because
he's not the worst thing yeah really
he didn't help no idea that he didn't
help the might think about he gave us
put the cookie down yeah no think about
it the two most entertaining things in
the movie for me
Schwarzenegger and Phil Hartman yeah um
so and none of them in that the funny
thing is you're right like none of them
are particularly good but they're still
the best things in it yeah in the pile
of crap they're the piece of corn on top
yeah uh so uh there it is a what a
lovely image and a fantastic comment on
the bear so cool that's about it uh
until next time
ja ja governor